what are you making the general state of
cable news because it gets a lot of crap
at you know from everybody all the time
and I'm not talking about you
specifically but in general you say
cable news and people start freaking out
right so what are you making the general
like sense of cable news well I think
it's you know obviously it's an easy
target
right the media excuse me the media is
always an easy target and so when you're
in that easy target that happens to be
on 24 hours a day you're gonna be an
even bigger target and when you're on
and there's no script there you know
then you're an even bigger target
because we are human and sometimes many
times most times there are no words in
that box to read when you're in cable
now if you're on broadcast it's a whole
different story if you're doing an
evening broadcast in national or local
everything is scripted for you you read
if you're doing a 30-minute newscast
maybe you read at the most five to seven
minutes of copy right you're saying oh
there's a big story out west is the
flooding and other about dave rubin
joins us with the latest Dave what do
you know boom and then that's it and you
go thank you Dave and now let's talk
about the president's you know reform on
gun control and you even talk like this
it's a very specific word sir for you in
bubble why are you saying it's thank you
and then most that you'll say is
incredible report Bob Wow cable you're
saying no listen that's not right the
facts aren't there hold on let me get my
information where the president said
back and such and other people are
screaming right now you talk wait wait
now you talk yeah there's a lot more
room for error there's a lot more people
talking back and forth it's a lot more
interesting to watch so of course people
are gonna you know we're gonna be a
target and sometimes is early so most of
the time not really because we're just
we're just we just happen to be on
television in very real moments a lot of
the time yeah so to that point how often
because I right now in this very second
I have an IFB in my ear just so that I
can hear you because it's the nature of
how we're doing Skype I think I don't
think you have one in right you're
you're just doing the Skype off the
computer but one other thing yeah there
okay we have proof but one of the things
I hear all the time and I think I
probably thought this too is that when
you're on cable news you're on
television in general there's someone in
your ear always barking orders at you
how often is that actually true for you
that that you're doing your broadcast
and someone is actually telling you what
to say and I'm not talking about the
technical stuff cut to commercial I mean
you know sometimes people tell you what
to say and sometimes you like amen thank
you
sometimes people are correcting you yeah
some people are like they're your other
ears they're listening to the guest and
this someone will say well you know well
it's gonna it's gonna affect the fourth
amendment and then soon the producer
will say the president never mentioned
the fourth amendment and you'll say hey
listen the president never mentioned the
fourth amendment right sometimes you'll
say it was an unalienable right and then
the producer will say inalienable right
so do their little things or I always
like to tell people that both this
recent example is we go on the air
everything is ready
in the show you know the open is
scripted right and it's like it you know
bah bah bah I don't swap this at a rally
and Iowa this is CNN tonight I'm Don
Lemon right and then all of a sudden
that you know introduced now let's go to
our panel Dave Rubin is here Ryan liz is
here and you know Kayleigh Mackin and
he's here so panel and then someone will
say stop and I'll go oh stand by they'll
say and then they'll roll the breaking
news animation you're like oh okay and
they'll go breaking news and you go
breaking news and they'll say there's
been a plane that's been diverted you
say there's been a claim that's been
diverted and then as you're talking
they'll say okay now go with prompter
and so all of this stuff you're talking
and then you look up and they say okay
joining us on the phone and they'll say
Bob Williams so say Bob Williams from
nebraska from nebraska and so you've you
know and sometimes you'll be in the
middle of a sentence and people will
talk to you so it does happen people at
home think you're stupid but actually
you're not that stupid you're just like
whoa what that's it and that's why I
wanted to ask you that because I think
there's this sense out there that you're
getting orders of what you can and
should say and and what you're really
saying is its technical stuff it's stuff
because we're we have a live program and
maybe they're fact-checking you but
they're not being like Don you better
explain what you meant by that you're
like oh oh what I meant was because some
someone might misconstrue it but it
doesn't really everything it's
misconstrued and everything now it gets
taken out of context like I can say okay
look Dave I let's not talk about the gay
thing right and then so we'll just take
that and say oh it's ashamed of being
gay and you're like no that was like a
half a sentence in an entire
conversation that we had and then it
builds upon itself and it keeps building
it's like a wildfire and by the time it
gets to the end it is absolutely nothing
to do with what you said and then people
believe it because the social media it's
really kind of ridiculous I want to
explore that somehow yeah people should
investigate that well it's something
that we've been talking about here a lot
because one of the things that I'm
seeing all the time now and
unfortunately I see this more on the
left is people being misquoted all the
time and no matter what you say and and
so that it's a good segue actually
because I think you in terms of the
mainstream media people you're the
victim of this all the time I mean every
time I open up mediate Don Lemon says
this Don Lemon this Sheppard go back and
look at the whole thing of what I said
you were like wait a minute that's not
what happened at all
well Don I don't have that kind of time
to listen to context but but that's
exactly what your point is that they get
you on the on the one-liner they know
that nobody's gonna go back and you know
watch the two minutes before the two
minutes after so for you how how aware
of that do you have to be and how much
are you thinking the whole time I better
not go there even though it's what I
really believe or it's not you know what
I want to say well I'm aware a little
bit but I can't do that to myself I
don't want to censor myself that way
because then you're not authentic and I
think that you know whatever success
I've achieved I think it's been through
authenticity and so if I was worried
about every single word and how it's
gonna be of course you want to be smart
right and you want to be buttoned up in
a certain way or I have your facts
straight I don't want to do that and so
if you want to take me out of context
and that's your business
and I think for the most part smart
people the viewers aren't dumb
they understand what's happening and
this stuff that happens online
especially like Twitter and all those it
doesn't usually translate to television
it certainly doesn't translate into
ratings and it doesn't translate into
credibility so you know you just it's
wonderful that I work for a network and
a boss who says constantly ignore the
noise you guys are doing great the
network is doing great our story is
great right now continue the momentum be
yourself
be smart keep moving and don't even read
it doesn't even matter if we tweet or
not or we don't have to read it it's a
it's amazing and wonderful we're in a
great spot right now on CNN so we don't
worry about that card right it's kind of
funny because on the social media side
you know like I could pick something
like when you said the the black hole
thing during the the plane thing and you
know you you're on air for hours you're
talking about all of this stuff you're
just throwing out you know somebody said
it could be a black hole like you
weren't saying it's in a black hole or
what like whatever it is and then next
thing you know Don Lemon is trending and
all that so you really you really can
just put it aside no I mean I can
because we listen we I've talked about
this ad nauseam the New York Times did a
thing on it it's at it's not that you
believe those things we had a thing
called crazy conspiracy theories that
people were sending to us yeah so one of
those was that it was a question from a
viewer that's it I've read the question
from a viewer and that was the end of
story and that's ago on a life of its
own but so be it it made me famous but
it's not not come from me that's not I'm
not positing that I'm saying hey look
this reviews this is what viewers are
saying they were also saying it was in a
hangar somewhere that we mentioned that
they were also saying that it was it was
flown someone else took it and hijacked
it there were a number of different
things that were said about it all of
which we talked about on social media
that one just happened to get picked up
yeah you know at the top of the show I
did a little piece on how I was saying
we need mainstream media but we also
need online media cuz I do believe we
need both for different reasons and
different corporate interests and all
that I think I think I think we look at
the online guy and
mainstream guys need more we need more
honest online people we need online
people online people who will actually
do their homework who will call who will
not write an article off of someone
else's article or off of someone else's
opinion of what someone else did online
people who actually saw the entire
segment in context to do their job not
just like lazy people are lazy and they
just go oh you know whatever yeah he
said that and you're like no that's not
so it's and it's kind of hard for us for
those of us who are in more traditional
media to chase all of those things down
and it's just not worth it yeah I mean
you literally took the words out of my
mouth that's exactly does it say because
I think at some point there was the
online media did was doing a lot of good
stuff getting to stories that maybe
hadn't bubbled up to you guys yet and
yet somehow in the last year or two
there's so many trashy sites that are
just waiting for you for not not just
the you know the on-air guys but for
politicians to just find any little
thing that they can say and run with
that just so that they can get clicks
and they're no longer doing a service
either it's what we call it click click
bait
so I we're at the point here at CNN
where we realize that I'm click bait so
just say Donlon and people are gonna
click on it yeah
so they will say down lemon and then
anything but what I wanted to say is oh
when you talk about online people so
have you ever worked for a traditional
network where you work for Sirius so it
that was an imagined that's pretty yeah
that was corporate that was corporate
it's so rigorous here before I could say
anything on the air as a fact or you
know present something it's got to go
through our fact checkers as it has to
go through standards and practices you
know what our definition of we were
talking about the guys in Oregon what
our definition of terrorism is all of
those things on how we confirm things we
had we the other night when Natalie Cole
died everyone was reporting Natalie Cole
died but we couldn't get in touch with
her her publicist because a publicist
was busy and every time we call the
phone was busy the email I guess right
we could not report that CNN would not
report that until we heard from an
official person online people don't have
those you know they don't have to climb
those hurdles and I think that's sad and
missing because listen we don't have to
be first we just want to be accurate
and I wish like I wish see online people
want it to be more accurate than first
or funny or opinionated yeah I totally
hear you I feel like I sort of exist in
between those two worlds and I'm just
trying to do what you're saying which is
which is be honest and have honest
conversations and even though I have one
of these things in my ear nobody's
yelling when they talk you know they're
nothing they're saying doing it you're
doing a hell of a job that's what they
just said so so the other thing that I
think is interesting about you is that
you get heat from both sides and I'm not
talking about when they misquote you now
I'm talking about if you say something
for example about black lives matter are
you taking a selfie right now I just
wanted this for I'm gonna do when I when
I post online good nice so that you get
equal heat from both sides so if you
take a black lives matter for example
there's a certain amount of racist
people who will look at you as a as a
black man and just they're gonna just
say racist it's just gonna come no
matter what and then there'll be people
when you've said things that haven't
been you know sort of in lockstep with
with the movement that'll say you're an
Uncle Tom and I'm only using that word
because when I googled you it was one of
the first words that came up that Don
Lemon is a trademark that word but go
ahead yeah that Don Lemon is an Uncle
Tom but to me it seems like you're
usually doing good stuff when people on
both sides are attacking you and that's
what you're getting all the time right
well yes and the thing that people
here's the thing that when I when we
talk about double standards and
expectations of people as a person of
color well someone just to say someone
not of color people don't expect you to
be the spokesman for all white men right
or all my god Yeah right
they don't even expect you to be the
spokesman for gay people somehow there's
this expectation of me to be the
spokesman for black people or gay people
and I am neither what I am the spokesman
for is information and truth and so if
black lives matter does something that
is worthy of criticism then it is my job
as a journalist to give that criticism
mm-hmm because no movement is perfect
even the civil rights movement wasn't
perfect and received its share of
criticism so there's a black person in
this position the only one who is in
primetime on
we'll network when people see that
coming for me they're like how dare you
well I'm not daring I'm doing my job
that is what I'm supposed to do so and
if someone who is white sees me talking
about black lives matter and in a way
that's positive then of course I agree
with them yeah so you know I I can't win
and so the the point is not to be an
advocate or someone who is you know an
activist my point is to be a journalist
yeah I get those races like if there's
homophobia I get there sexism but at the
end of the day what I'm giving is
information or if I say you know I just
received information that you know my co
that the cop in the Michael Brown case
is not going to be indicted that word is
going to come out people who want him to
be indicted are gonna get upset and call
me an Uncle Tom because it came out of
my mouth yeah and then 20 minutes later
when the guy comes out and says there's
no indictment no-one goes oh he was
right they just go oh he's covering that
story I can't believe him you know so
it's just it is what it is people take
out their frustrations on the person who
is in front of them and I happen to be
that person and do you find that a lot
of it it's odd that like with the Uncle
Tom stuff that that comes from people on
the left that they would want you right
the people on the Left they should see
you as an individual except what they're
seeing or what they're complaining about
is that you should be this
representative of black America or
whatever to find that the people who are
supposed to be the most tolerant are the
least because they they never consider
that they in fact may not be because
they think that everyone thinks like
them yeah and not everybody thinks like
you so you know concern
I find that listen I get it from all
sides but I find that the people who are
most incredulous about things and many
times the most vocal are liberals yeah
yeah yeah and and many times for me as
well African Americans because they were
looking at me regardless of the facts
even if the facts don't pan out even if
the evidence and all the investigations
and all the autopsies show no hands up
don't shoot I have to come on television
and say hands up don't shoot I can't
that's not what the evidence shows so I
have to say the evidence does not show
that so that never happened according to
the evidence but I can't believe you you
sell out any like well I what do you
want me to do lie I can't lie right and
then that's exactly where they go oh
it's because he's getting the
information from his ear I think you've
Illustrated is actually not the case
okay so a lot of people have been asking
me this on Twitter and I thought you'd
be the perfect person to pose this
question to the way the media frames
certain things so the way the media
frames black lives matter versus how the
media is now framing this Oregon militia
thing now and we don't have to get into
the Nitty Gritty of every little
instance that's happening but a lot of
people were saying you know that the
media is not calling these Oregon people
they're not calling them terrorists and
if this was a group of black people or
especially if this was a group of Muslim
people we would be calling them
terrorists and I I was googling the word
terrorism and you know it talks about
intimidation or violence not and
violence and to me it's a little hazy
whether them taking this building where
they had to use no force per se and you
know apparently the building was just
open and yes they had guns and it's
federal property and so whether it's
actually terrorism and would the media
be treating it differently if it was
either black people or Muslim why are
you falling into that trap devar but I
tell you this trap how about that so
here's the thing so I actually wrote an
editorial saying that it was terrorists
in my editorial for the Tom Joyner
Morning Show and so you know it was read
by someone here at CNN and they said
well our definition of terrorism here at
CNN is different is that it has to be
political it is political it also has to
have someone who has been hurt by it
like physically hurt so it's not
terrorism until someone is actually hurt
or killed or what-have-you and I think
that's part of the definition here but
according to the law enforcement people
I spoke to if you are doing something
for a political end or whatever that is
illegal in that manner then it is
terrorism so I have called it terrorism
I've heard other people call it
terrorism I don't know how other media
organizations frame it but here at CNN I
don't think there is a double standard
about
what's going on and what it is now
here's the thing is it do I know that if
you know would it be different if it was
Muslims or if it was black black people
yeah of course I live in America I know
that in this particular case so I have
to have to hedge it and say I'm not so
sure and here's why because it is in the
middle of nowhere
it's 280 miles from Portland Oregon the
big next biggest city burns is what 80
or 30 or 80 miles away and no one really
knows where burns Oregon is right so it
is basically a truck stop not even a
truck stop and a rest stop in the middle
of nowhere
what the government is trying to do the
FBI is trying to do is to avoid another
Ruby Ridge and another wake up yeah and
so it is the middle of winter nobody's
there nobody is in danger of being heard
the best thing that these guys can do is
be ignored I hate that we even have to
give them media attention because
they're Yahoo's they're not within their
legal right for anything so I think what
they're doing now is perfectly fine let
them sit there in the middle of winter
and freeze their asses off and fine if
you want to stay down in the middle of
winter in that little crappy building
then that is your business yes it is a
federal building and they are breaking
the law and at some point they will have
to take care of it but I think at this
point I think they're actually doing the
right thing as far as a media reaction I
know I haven't seen any I don't know
anyone who's called it like a peaceful
protest or what-have-you I did it is
what it is
it's people who are ignorant of the law
who have taken over a building and they
should pay for the pay the consequences
when the time comes but right now I say
ignore them yeah and I'm pretty sure
they're not gonna get what they want at
the end of it they're not that's usually
just how all these things ran and it's
many of the people whose land was saved
by the government helping them out years
ago
yeah and now they want to reclaim it and
get the money back that they're more
money than was already given to them
they're just ignorant of the law if this
was a building that mattered in the
middle of a city that mattered sure
reaction would be completely different
yeah and there would be more direct
threat to be more of a direct threat yes
but I do think that they're getting a
pass there because of their
legend they're not Muslim because
they're you know white not
african-american I do but I don't know
how different the reaction would really
be I don't know because it's a building
that nobody cares about in a city in a
place that nobody really cares about
yeah and it's only 15 about 15 or so
people who are actually in that building
it's not hundreds of people yeah they're
running out of snacks I heard so this
thing can't last that long they're
idiots